-It is time for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ Good name, bad name,
great name, yes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First up we have
About Damn Time.
That's a good name
for a new song by Lizzo.
It's a bad name
for a funeral parlor.
It's a great name for a store
that sells engagement rings.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After that, we've got BuzzFeed.
Well, that's a good name
for a news site.
It's a bad name
for a hair salon.
It's a great name
for a 3:00 a.m.
drive-thru line at Taco Bell.
[ Applause ]
Next, there's The Staircase.
Well, that is a good name
for an HBO show.
It's a bad name for an Airbnb.
It's a great name for a
courtroom drama about a Slinky.
Oh, interesting.
[ Applause ]
-Alone or in pairs?
-He was pushed!
[ Laughter ]
-After that, there's Break Free.
Well, that's good name for
a song by Ariana Grande.
A bad name for a prison.
[ Laughter ]
A great name for taking off
your Spanx after a wedding.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Pop ]
And finally, we have Ain't No
Mountain High Enough.
Well, that's a good name
for a song.
That is a bad name
for a pilot school.
It's a great name for trying to
get service when you have AT&T.
There you go. That is "Good
Name, Bad Name, Great Name."